We're asked to simplify d times
4d to the 1/2 power.
So let's see what
we can do here.
And I think there's multiple
ways to kind of simplify it,
and we'll explore all of them.
So d times 4d to the 1/2.
4d to the 1/2, let me just focus
on that right there.
4d to the 1/2.
If you take the product of two
things and you raise that to
an exponent, that's the same
thing as taking each of those
terms to that exponent and
then taking the product.
So 4d to the 1/2 is the same
thing as 4 to the 1/2 times d
to the 1/2.
And of course, you have
this d out front.
And I could put the parentheses
here, but it
doesn't matter at this point.
Now you just have three
things that you're
taking the product of.
So I'll put this d out
front just like that.
And now there's a couple of ways
you could think about it.
You have this 4 to the 1/2 power
and you're taking its
principal square root, so its
positive square root.
So that right there
is going to be 2.
So 4 to the 1/2, that
right there is going
to be equal to 2.
And then, there's a couple of
ways you could think about it.
You have this d out front.
And then you have
a d to the 1/2.
And there's several ways that
you can now represent this,
depending on what you feel--
I don't know--
aesthetically pleasant.
You could say, well look, this
is d to the first power.
This is d to the 1/2 power.
I could add them.
So one way to say it is it's 2
times d to the 1 plus 1/2.
You can either say 1 and
1/2 power or 3/2
power if you want.
So that's one simplification
of this expression.
Another simplification would be
well, you could say, look.
d to the 1/2, that is the same
thing as the square root of d.
So you could say this is the
same thing as 2 times d times
the square root of d.
So any of these are actual
simplifications, but it's
interesting to see that
they're really all
representing the same thing.